- [Narrator] How have
congressional elections
changed over time?
- Congressional elections
used to be separate
from the presidential elections.
One of the great examples is in 1938,
FDR, who we all look back and think of
as a president who had
such extraordinary power
and who could do no wrong,
well in 1938 he tried to see if he could
exercise that power.
So he tried to kick some Democrats
out of the Democratic Party
who didn't agree with him
and he was spectacularly unsuccessful.
Lots and lots of the Democrats
he put his finger on and
told his fellow Democrats,
"You vote for my man,"
and they lost.
Other Democrats won
and that gives you a sense
of how the president,
even a popular and successful one,
was very separate from his own party.
Well, what's happened since then
is that presidents have started
to have much more control
over the members of their own party
and voters, who in 1938,
thought it was outrageous
that a president would force Democrats
of his own party to vote
the way he wanted them to
because they saw such a separation between
the Presidency and the Congress.
Those voters don't exist much any more.
Voters now pay a, penalize,
a member of a party
who doesn't stick with their president
of that same party.
So that connectedness
tends to create a situation
in which congressional
elections in the midterms
tend to be a referendum on the president
even though the president's
not on the ballot.
What's also the other big
change in American politics
is the amount of money.
In 2018 it's very likely that according to
the Center for Responsive Politics
five billion dollars will
be spent on the election.
10 years ago, in the election of 2008,
spending was half that.
2.5 billion dollars and
that was a presidential year
in which there's more spending.
The enormous amount of money
means you have more ads,
you means you have a whole group of people
who's job it is to make decisions
that are subtle and
complicated and complex
seem easy and to intensify
the partisan battles
between each other.
And that also creates a situation in which
candidates are always running for office
because they're always
having to raise the money
to pay for all of those ads,
and all of those experts,
and all of those social media campaigns.
Speaking of social media,
we now have an instance in which you have
real time up or down
votes from constituents
and people on the sidelines
telling members of
Congress whether they're
doing the right thing or
doing the wrong thing,
either in office or in elections,
and that creates a real time
jitteriness to elections.
It used to be you could have
a long time conversation.
Heck when Abraham Lincoln
and Stephen Douglas
debated in those famous
Lincoln/Douglas debates
for a Senate seat,
those debates took place over three hours.
Now we have situations
where people will flame up
for about 20 minutes on Twitter
and that's all the time you'll ever see
for something to get addressed
because 10 more issues have come along
in the next 20 minutes.
So social media has
sped up and intensified
the nature of conflict in campaigns
and those are some of the
big things that have changed
in the way we run our
congressional campaigns.